hey youtubers it's Charlie so since we
finally found out what all the Marvel TV
shows are gonna be this fall as well as
early next year I wanted to do a
breakdown of everything we also found
out that agents of shield is getting a
season two as well but I'll talk about
that whenever I post my shield finale
video later tonight if you're finding me
for the first time I do Marvel videos
every week I try to post them on
Tuesdays usually like Marvel Tuesdays
unless Warner Brothers and DC decide
they want to drop some bombs like for
instance the new Batmobile they're gonna
be announcing that pretty soon be sure
to subscribe to get everything
also because agents of shield is going
on hate is soon I'm just replacing those
videos with Star Wars videos so
Tuesday's will be like Marvel's Star
Wars days feel free to leave me
suggestions for bonus videos so I'm just
gonna do a breakdown of all these shows
one at a time starting with number one
agent Carter this is the Peggy Carter TV
show that's premiering this fall it's
already been picked up for a half season
meaning it'll get 13 episodes they
haven't announced a premiere date but I
expect it to air alongside agents of
shield season 2 that show premiered at
the end of September last year so
tentatively plan on it starting sometime
in September Hayley Atwell is reprising
the role of Peggy Carter from the
Captain America films which I'm really
excited about in case you haven't seen
it yet there was this Marvel one-shot
called Peggy Carter that picked up right
after the events of the first Captain
America film the show is gonna take
place in 1946 and she'll be going on
secret missions for the SSR and Howard
Stark that's the precursor of shield
because she's doing that at night her
day job is basically being a secretary
you know apparently they did not treat
women so hot back then just think Mad
Men Howard Stark is gonna be a character
on the show but we don't know if
Dominique Cooper is gonna reprise his
role or how many episodes that character
is gonna be in it sounds like people are
expecting him to come back but Howard
Stark himself to only be in a couple of
episodes of season it's really all about
the Peggy Carter character so it would
be like samuel l.jackson being on agents
of shield all the time it would steal
focus from Clark Gregg and the rest of
the cast we will probably get to see
some really cool 1940s stark tech though
maybe even some of that Lola repulsor
tech the dauphin the first Captain
America film so moving along next we
have the Netflix series there's
daredevil Jessica Jones Luke Cage and
iron fist each of the shows are going to
premiere really close to the same time
each other in 2015 there's no official
release date for any of them yet but
expect them to premiere somewhere near
Avengers age of Ultron which is May 1st
each of those Netflix shows is gonna get
13 one-hour episodes each and they're
gonna dump them all at once you know
house of cards style they're basically
pitching them to us as four different 13
hour movies they're calling it a binge
friendly approach but the really cool
thing is is the stories from each of
those Netflix shows is building towards
an Avenger style team-up called the
defenders that's gonna be a miniseries
so think of it is like a four-hour
Avengers movie the stories will all
exist inside the Marvel shared universe
but they're gonna be their own separate
thing you know just like agents of
shield only crossed over with the movies
very briefly so we're not going to see
Tony Stark in them or any of the other
Avengers but the events of those shows
will influence what's going on later in
agents of shield and in the movies so
there will be connective tissue at a
story level personally when I first
heard the news I got a little bit
nervous about having to binge watch 52
hours of TV and try to do videos for all
those things but I'm not gonna worry
about it right now it's so far off I'll
deal with the videos that I'm gonna do
for it later but in the meantime I will
be doing bonus videos for the news but
like whenever they start casting people
that's still one of the big things that
they have to do this year I wouldn't be
surprised that they announced to
splaying you know daredevil Jessica
Jones Luke Cage and iron fist at Comic
Con don't expect it to happen in Hall H
though remember agents of shield was a
whole separate panel and Marvel only has
one hour in Hall H to talk about four or
five movies so they'll probably use one
of their other TV panels to talk about
the Netflix shows I am really excited
about Marvel and Disney releasing all
this content on Netflix so I will
definitely be doing videos for it as we
get more news based on previous Avengers
experience I think we can plan for each
of these different shows to deal with
origin stories you know just like the
separate Avengers films establish those
characters before they did the big
Avengers team-up movie don't worry if
you haven't read the comics each of the
TV shows will tell you everything you
need to know about the characters but
the writers are always really good about
laying in Easter eggs for people that
are big comics with fans they haven't
said whether or not they intend for the
show's to continue and get more than one
season but if they're successful I'm
sure they'll just keep making them house
of cards for example was so successful
that they greenlit season 3 before
season 2 ever started
I think the real reason though that
Marvel and Disney chose Netflix to
release these series is because there's
such a limited space on broadcast
television for new shows I mean they
already have two superhero shows and
that's considered a lot so obviously
they chose Netflix which has an infinite
amount of space but now it's your turn
let me know in the comments below are
you excited to see a piggy Carter TV
show and all these Netflix shows you
know personally I'm really excited to
see a new you know female based
superhero you know comic book show I
know a lot of the fandom is also
wondering when we're gonna see that
first female movie and odds are on Black
Widow just because she's already been
established so like I said tons of stuff
happening this week be sure to subscribe
to get everything I also posted a link
to my master schedule down in the
description right now you can click here
to get my shield finale video and you
can click here to see my latest Justice
League video thank you so much for
watching I'll see you guys tomorrow
high fives
you